Bill bur came in today Bill Bill's all
excited about bad dads are you saying it
wrong on purpose old dads old dads I'm
sorry I I'm confusing with bad moms old
dads great movie Bill's excited
obviously I watched it with Liz we both
enjoyed it I think old dads is a bad
title for the movie I think it doesn't
let you know how good it's going to be
you know what would have been a better
title Aaron what bad dads bad dads tells
you exactly what you're getting old dads
I don't know what's old that's relative
bad that's absolute
the're bad dads sure bad old dads bad
old dads is good bad dads is good the
movie is great Bill's all excited rolls
up in here in his brand new Mini Cooper
that he's all proud of except wants to
drive us around we're like we got to do
the podcast and then he just did
wheelies and I don't mean Donuts I mean
wheelies in the parking lot for 5 10
minutes screaming out battle dads Bobby
Kon valy was just like why do I have to
be riding shotgun for this every time
you do it Bobby's great in the movie
check out battle dads on uh on Netflix